merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues 3
années ont passé la douleur de
l'assassinat de Samuel pati est encore
présente rouverte à
vif par celui de Dominique Bernard à
aras ma ville où l'émotion est à son
comble une fois de plus l'école est une
cible pour ceux qui en veulent à nos
valeurs qui en veulent à notre publ mais
le terroriste a trouvé sur son chemin
des héros avec un sang-froid admirable
enseignant agents policiers au péril de
leur propre vie en ont sauvé de
nombreuses et les mots sont trop faibles
pour les remercier et leur rendre
hommage et si le temps est au deuil et
au recueillement il n'occulte pas tout à
fait les questions après trois décennies
d'attentats et une trentaine de lois
l'arsenal juridique et policier existe
est-il suffisant l'attentat d'arace
montre malheureusement qu'il y a des
failles alors pour autant une aème loi
de circonstances n'a guerre d'intérêt
j'en appelle donc à la sagesse du Sénat
pour trouver dans la future loi
immigration les réponses justes et
fermes mais il faut miser aussi et
surtout sur une véritable politique
éducative et parentale impératif pour
réarmer moralement la jeunesse l'école
doit demeurer un sanctuaire à l'abri de
la violence de certains foyers et des
idéologies mortifères un lieu où on
apprend et on sémencipe alors monsieur
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
vous avez rencontré des enseignants à
ras bouleversés par le drame ils
attendent vos réponses à leurs questions
et je vous en pose deux qu'allez-vous
faire pour assurer la protection des
établissements scolaires les grilles et
les circulaires ne suffiront pas et
qu'allez-vous faire aussi pour que le
éducatif et civique mené par Samuel
Patier Dominique Bernard et que mè tous
les enseignants de notre pays ne soit
pas 20
merci